rates on currency dealers have become
common in Ghana
the city has become one of the world's
worst performing currencies losing 60
percent of its value against major
currencies like the British pound Euro
and American dollars since the start of
the year
the government believes currency
speculation is making that worse and is
clumping down
but currency Traders like review Maude
says the raids are targeting the wrong
people
it is just low hanging fruits the people
that actually help with the Palo markets
or the black market are powerful
politicians and Powerful business people
that have those resources those funds to
be able to buy the kinds of volumes that
will drive prices up the person who does
Black Market is the low-hanging fruit is
the lowest on the chain
is customers range from businessmen to
Travelers and even government officials
Ghana Imports most of its manufactured
goods and footstaff
the pandemic war in Ukraine and Rising
oil prices have all damaged its heavily
indebted economy
and with industrial output down the
demand for foreign currencies has
increased
rates on foreign currency dealers like
this have forced many of them
underground this led to shortages adding
pressure to the local currency of the
city
most affected when inflation the
government says his actions are
necessary what we have sought to do is
to take off the table the element of
speculation by a getting the central
bank to regularly provide updates on the
interbank Forex rates and B going in
hard on those who are operating in the
black market and are just shooting up
the rates
experts accuse the government of
skirting around a bigger problem
what has cost the city is our fiscal
irresponsibility
restore fiscal responsibility and the
city's confidence will come back
currency Traders say the transactions
account for only five percent or foreign
currency transactions in Ghana
but the black market is estimated to
transact nearly 30 percent of such deals
and that's the volume the government
wants to reduce Accra